well February is Black History Month and
since it began in the 70s schools and
businesses have celebrated in great and
not so great ways and you might recall
last year target-faced backlash for some
of its merchandise they had a collection
of t-shirts that were very controversial
fig strategy and Consulting says it's a
perfect example of what not to do during
this time fig offers diversity equity
and inclusion Consulting and Training
Services it says common practices like
problematic merchandise and what's
described as the one month Ally can be
insensitive
it's important to have these
conversations that we can number one
take action do better and be more
sensitive to
black people in this country
well if you encounter this speak up use
it as an opportunity to educate fig
Consulting says that it's all of our
responsibility to say it's not okay